اتابع هذه التغطيه كما نشاهد في هذه الصور
عمليه الاقتحام مستمره لاشتباكات ايضا
مستمره في هذا المربع وبهذا انتقل اليك
وليد العمري ما اذا كان لديك اي تحديثات
تتعلق
باعداد الاصابات او الشهداء او بما يجري
في المنطقه على
اولا مصادر الجيش الاسرائيلي تتحدث عن
انهم الشبين المحاصرين قد استشهداء اي انه
قتلهما داخل المبنى المذكور المصادر
الفلسطينيه والشهود العيان يقولوا انه من
الصعوبه الوصول الى المبنى لان قوات
الاحتلال منتشره بكثافه وما زالت تحاصر
المنطقه بالكامل الاحصائيات المتوفره
تتحدث عن شهيدين وربما هناك ثالث المصادر
الفلسطينيه وهناك حتى الان 45 اصابه
بالرصاص الحي بالاضافه الى نحو 250 اصابه
بالاختناق والاعايره المطاطيه ومن بين
الاصابات بالرصاص الحي رقم سبعه خطيره وهو
ما يشير الى احتمال ان يكون هناك ازدياد
في عدد الشهداء حتى اللحظه هناك قوات
الاحتلال التي دخلت بعشرات الاليات وبعض
الشهود الاعيان قدروها باكثر من 50 اليه
مصفحه دخلت على دفعتين هذه القوات تسد
منافذ البلده القديمه تحديدا منطقه الشرطي
في البلده القديمه التي يقع فيها البيت
المستهدف الذي قصف في اللحظه الاولى باربع
صواريخ مضاده للدروع وادعت السلطات
الاحتلال انها هناك مطلوبين لها كما قالت
وحسب المعلومات الفلسطينيه فان هناك كان
اثنين من المقاتلين من عارين الاسود لكنها
دخلت واغلقت المنطقه بالكامل المواجهات
وقعت في محيط البلده القديمه على مداخلها
لان البلده القديمه سدتها قوات الاحتلال
بمدرعاتها والياتها العسكريه وكميه
النيران التي كانت تطلق سواء باشتباكات
متبادله او تلك التي اطلقتها قوات
الاحتلال على المواطنين المحتجين
كان واضحا بانها بكميات هائله الهلال
الاحمر افاد اكثر من مره بانه وجد صعوبه
جمع في محاوله الوصول واسعاف المصابين لان
قوات الاحتلال كانت تمنعه طيله الوقت حتى
اللحظه كما قلنا هناك شهيدان ربما ثالث
ايضا لم يتاكد وهناك حديث انسحاب بقوات
الاحتلال مثلا من هذا الشارع وهذا الحياه
عاده عندما تنهي مهمتها بالقتل تقوم
بتبدا بالانسحاب المعلومات التي وردت في
اللحظه الاخيره ان هناك عدد الشهداء ارتفع
الى خمسه شهداء من بينهم الشابين داخل
البنايه في البلده القديمه التي استهدفتها
قواتها الاحتلال بالاضافه الى ثلاثه
مواطنين احدهم مسن في الثانيه والسبعين من
عمره وقد استشهدوا في خارج البلده القديمه
خلال اطلاق قوات الاحتلال النيران على
المواطنين الذين كانوا يحتجون كما قلت
المعلومه الاخيره ان في نابلس خمسه شهداء
ومعنى ذلك ان هناك اكثر من 45 اصابه
بالرصاص الحي الجريحا من بينهم سبعه منها
خطيره وهناك اكثر من 250 حاله اختناق
وايضا
المطاطيه هذا الهجوم الاسرائيلي في قلب
مدينه نابلس شاركت فيه قوات مشتركه من
الجيش ومن والوحده الخاصه في الشرطه
المعروفه باليابان ومن الوحده الخاصه في
حرس الحدود بالاضافه الى وحدات وعناصر
كوماندوز مما يعرف بالمستعربين وهي وحدات
يتخفى عناصرها بالزي المدني عدد خمسه
شهداء هذا يشمل ايضا الشابين الذين دار
الحديث عن انهما داخل المبنى وهما حسام
سليم ومحمد الجنيدي والذي قال جيش
الاحتلال انه قام بهذه العمليه
ودخلفهما طبيعه المنطقه المستهدفه ايضا في
هذا الحي هو هو سوق شعبي مقتد
بالماره المتسوقين بسكان ايضا كما نشاهد
في هذه الصور بدايات على كل الاطراف هل
هذا يفسر عدد الاصابات المرتفع الى هذا
الحد
[موسيقى]
ما يفسر ان قوات الاحتلال اطلقت النيران
ليس فقط في الاشتباكات المسلحه داخل
البلده القديمه وانما على المحتجين
المسلمين من الاهالي والمواطنين على مداخل
البلده القديمه في مدينه نابلس قوات
الاحتلال عاده تدخل من اكثر من محور وهذه
المره هي دخلت بعد ان امن لها عناصرها
المتخفين بالزي المدني
امنوا لها هذا الدخول والشهود الاعيان
تحدثوا ايضا عن انها كانت هناك مسيرات
تشارك بعمليه اطلاق النار بالاضافه الى
طائرات اباتشي والعدد عدد الاليات التي
دخلت الى مدينه نابلس كان كبيرا بشكل لافت
بمعنى انها اضطرت الى الدفع بتعزيزات بعد
ان ادخلت قواتها الاولى دفعت بتعزيزات
كبيره على عدد الكبير هو لان المواطنين
هبوا في محاولتهم للتصدي لقوات الاحتلال
على مداخل البلده القديمه التي سدتها قوات
الاحتلال باليات المدرعه هل سجل
الساعات الماضيه اي مواقف ان كان من
الفصائل الفلسطينيه على المستوى الفلسطيني
الرسمي او الشعبي
[موسيقى]
الموقف الوحيد وصلنا من الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه من الناطق نبيل ابو ردينه وهو
يطالب بوقف العدوان فورا كما جاء فيه
ويقول بان قوات الاحتلال تعتدي على الشعب
الفلسطيني عاده بيان الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
يدعو ايضا الى تدخل دولي عاجل لوقف كافه
اشكال الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه ضد
الفلسطينيين ومتوقع ان تكون هناك بيانات
الى حد ما مشابهه من فصائل الفلسطينيه
اخرى المجموعات التي ظهرت مجموعات
المقاومين التي ظهرت في نابلس وجنين عرين
الاسود وكذلك كتيبه جنين عناصرها ينحذرون
من فصائل مختلفه لذلك هم يتصدرون المشهد
الان الفصائل الفلسطينيه لا تظهر في اطار
المقاومه كفصائل مسلحه او في عمليات
مقاومه لكن
اللافت ان هذا الاعتداء الاسرائيلي في قلب
مدينه نابلس واسرائيل تستبيح
الحاله الفلسطينيه بالكامل سواء على صعيد
اقتحامات وقتل او على صعيد استيطان او على
صعيد
هدم منازل وتشريد عائلات تستبيحها
باعتقادها ان هذا مشرع لها لان ليس هناك
موقف دولي جدي هي تعير اهميه فقط ومثل ما
تفضل ضيفكما الكريمان ابو عواد وشديد من
قبل
للموقف الامريكي والموقف الامريكي حتى
الساعه ليس موقفا ملزما لاسرائيل ولو اراد
الامريكيون لكان بوسعهم ان يلزموا هذا
الموقف او هذا السلوك الاسرائيلي باستهداف
المدنيين الفلسطينيين ليس بالامر الجديد
هو بدا الى حد بعيد اذا اسعفتني الذاكره
عندما قصفت اسرائيل مدرسه بحر البقر في
مصر وقتلت غرفت مجزره في حينه في ابريل
عام 70 في خلال حرب الاستنزاف عندما دمرت
واغرقت القوات المصريه المدمره ايلات
وقتلت عددا كبيرا من جنودها وملاحيها
انذاك سئلت رئيسه الوزراء الاسرائيلي
جولدا مائير عن سبب قصف مثل البحر البقر
وقتل هذا العدد الكبير من الاطفال والطلبه
قالت كلمه واحده ردت قالت سكيورتي اي امن
اي بمعنى ان كل شيء مستباح تحت يافطه
الامن الاسرائيلي نعم ابقى معنا